what doesn't kill you makes you stronger
my personal life is kind of like
divorce is a really thing
it's horrible horrible and expensive
e.t has learned that kelly who was
spotted today looking somber as she
headed to work
has been ordered to pay her estranged
husband brandon blackstock nearly 200
000 dollars a month that breaks down to
150 thousand dollars in spousal support
and 45 grand in child support for their
kids remy and river
that huge payout is interesting
considering kelly actually has primary
physical custody
et has also learned brandon is no longer
a producer
on kelly's talk show i care 100
more about my children than i do
anything else on this planet
kelly's worth an estimated 45 million
dollars how do her payouts compare to
other a-listers
well if you look at just kelly's child
support that 45 thousand dollar figure
is close to what britney spears pays her
ex kevin fetterline
britt who's worth about 60 mil pays 40
000 a month it's all about the kids
that's what it's for
unlike kelly's case britney's boys jade
and preston
spend most of their time with their dad
they're supposed to be able to live a
life that they're accustomed to
paying way less than kelly actress halle
berry she and her ex gabriel aubry were
never actually married
but they have joint custody of their
daughter nala hallie was recently paying
the canadian model 16
000 a month in child support
all that pales in comparison to dr dre
who was ordered to pay almost 300
000 a month in spousal support to his ex
nicole young
child support is not a factor since
their kids are no longer minors
dray's reportedly worth 820 million
you